right now life is good I got money I got
a belt dude everything is good but like
you couldn't pay me to go [__] relive
my life like you said hey Sean you want
to go hit the restart button like [__]
you really [__] no but what if you got
to a place one day where you were able
to like like be because at a certain
point I think like people from a tough
environment become Inspirations for
people from a tough environment you know
oh yeah no I mean I I get guys like well
call me crying yeah I mean I've heard
some of the [__] you've got man you get
some crazy [__] too dude yeah yeah we
get some guys that have been through a
lot of stuff dude and the guys that are
perverts everything yeah look at that
guy that's me oh my god dude this is you
before the dude cuz you had a motor you
had your motorcycle accident you think
after your motorcycle accident you you
became a different guy you think so when
I was
younger I was like a pseudo white
supremacist yeah right [__] believe
that right who would have thought that I
mean I was like the pseudo white
supremacist I'm talking about like let's
just say like six to like dud a lot of
that yeah we all go through that we all
go through that as a white man you know
yeah anyways so I was like I'll tell you
why I look like in that
photo so I was like dude I mean it was
rough man like I got kicked out of high
school for hate crimes did you really
yeah yeah I didn't graduate high school
I didn't graduate Elementary School that
if kids miss a certain amount of school
the parents get you know the parents get
go to jail so me and like third grade
just ditching school being a [__]
idiot you know staying home to watch a
porn box like
[Music]
sorry I'm thinking about the porn box in
it's all right dude so you out of home
you watching the porn box in the commun
one and then like all of a sudden my mom
gets a call like a letter in the mail
saying hey if Sean doesn't go to school
you can go to jail so now she has a
choice homeschool my kid has she had a
full-time job or go to jail damn so my
little mowgly ass I'm like the little
wild one dude they put my ass home
school I didn't go to school I didn't
read I don't think I learned how to read
until I came an adult you know I was
homeschooled dude imagine I wasn't
socialized bro I was like a dog that you
have to go let people pet you know like
nobody no and where was this at where
were you guys an inland empire an inland
empire so I go back to school Ry yeah so
you know now I'm like in seventh grade
and my mom's like we should probably put
this kid back to school right like
[__] worst thing she could have did
did you ever were you and so you were
you had some education at that point I
mean but it's hard I've never like they
triy to hold me back in kindergarten
like I mean I was like zero dude like
thank God for computers man so anyways I
go to seventh grade and I get kicked out
of school for like a hate crime so what
they do is did you really do it or not I
mean I probably just called somebody a
or dropped the inbomb like it probably
you know it was like but it's also
different time bro it's different
[__] time like racism was way more
common back in like you know 20 years
ago yeah so anyways I get put in this
thing where they isolate you they put
you in a a group that they let you in
school like 2 hours later and they let
you out like 2 hours earlier so they
tried to keep you from the the
kids so I started ditching again I got
homeschooled again in middle school I
went back into High
School uh ninth grade I got kicked out
of school for a hate crime I think I uh
I don't know I beat up some or something
I mean I beat up I beat up a guy I made
I I don't hate [__] gays yeah no I
don't hate anybody I don't think I uh I
don't know there's a couple people that
I really don't [__] like boy but like
I had a lot of like dude I had a lot of
[__] trauma you had a lot of anger
though a lot I'm growing up you know I
had this piece of [__] grandfather he
was super racist big white man you know
did he like you at all you think though
no he he did you know he did but like
you know you're a kid with a piece of
[__] father and like you just gravitate
towards anything masculine and like
this's a big old white racist red neck
and I'm angry so next thing I know dude
I'm like right you're just saying racist
[__] you heard at the house yeah yeah
exactly so I get kicked out and then I
started training like ninth like ninth
grade I started training and then dude
like
I realized I wasn't racist I was just
angry I mean I I'll never forget d I
always tell people the first day I
trained I got the [__] kicked out of me
covered in blood bro like first moment
in my life I ever felt happiness first
moment in my [__] life I ever felt
happiness getting [__] kicked out of me
just all the anger the went gone why do
you think a lot of it just comes out
when you're because I had a moment where
I was uh like I was just training ji-
Jitsu for a while and there would be
times after the end of class where I
would just kind of start tear like just
so much emotion would come out of all
the anger but I mean again dude like you
know I mean why I got so mad drus like I
went through like pretty severe trauma
as a kid like pretty [__] up trauma
well like I could sit there and joke
about it but I mean dude I remember like
I remember I've told the story once dude
like I was in probably third fourth
grade and [__] man uh I used to always
sleep in my mom's room because I thought
my dad was going to kill my mom so like
I would like sleep by the door I'd sleep
to make sure she was all right yeah
sleep I'd sleep under theed bed you know
I'd sleep by the door cuz I thought my
dad was going to kill my mom so like one
day dude is so [__] up like it was
just kind a bad fight like third fourth
grade and I uh my dad's like [__] that
he's not sleeping he's not sleeping here
tonight he's not like kick him out and
so I like army crawl under the bed and
I'm sleeping under the bed right under
the bed under the I'm like laying on the
bed like just laying underneath the bed
like as they're fighting cuz I think my
dad's going to kill my mom wow he was
that violent yeah he's just coward you
know so anyways like I remember we had
like dogss you know we white trash and
the house was like flea infested you
have a dog in there with you no no dog
was there with me but I remember laying
under the
bed and like fleas were just like
jumping all over me you know I'm like I
think there might have been like a dildo
next to me I sh you not dude oh man
sucks we got this kind of like orange
looking carpet so picture like me like
third fourth grade yeah laying under a
bed fleas jumping all over me there's a
[__] like dildo next to
me
yeah sounds like a Japanese game show
who puts a dildo underneath the bed BR
it's not sanitary put it like put it in
your [__] drawer yeah at least put it
in a drawer that has a bunch of gum and
coins in it under the bear the police
yeah
dude that's scary dud so anyways my dad
gets on top of my mom she says like I
remember he said like I'm gonna [__]
I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna [__]
kill you tonight get maybe just rough
sex we don't know at this moment right
and you were under the bed I'm under the
bed so he starts strangling her and I
get out and I only thing I can see is a
guitar I just [__] crack him in the
head call the cops and then he gives a I
run down the street call his cop gets
arrested my dumb ass mom ba him out of
jail oh but it's like I mean even that
like I mean that was like I wouldn't
even say that's tip of the iceberg I
remember like being a little kid so I
would always miss
school because my dad would get home
drunk start drinking at like six he
would get home at like
7 and and like just be be up until like
3: in the morning just like tell myom
tell drinking tell my mom she's a [__]
going to kill her like and I remember I
used to like what a loser huh sorry to
say that about your dadie [__] died of
cancer but anyways he's on of cancer now
yeah yeah he died of cancer yeah [__]
you know probably from the hate inside
of him bill I hate to say that he was
just drugs D lots lots of drugs pain
pills why I don't do drugs so I remember
like I used to sit there and just kind
of like hug my mom's leg in the in the
kitchen mhm you know like we had this
little Nook and she would like go on the
Nook and I would just sit there like all
night long I'm by like the feet of my
mom and my dad like I'm going to [__]
kill you and this and that and I'll
never forget like he would talk about
like like burn her face with acid and
mind you I'm in elementary school I'm in
elementary school right so like so
that's a lot of responsibility than you
feel probably just to like take care of
your mom oh yeah yeah now he'd always
tell her that like if you cheat on me
and she probably was cheating on him if
you cheat on me I'm going to like cut
you up and put you in a bottle of acid
and bury you so now you fast forward
this like I don't go to school I'm up
till 3: in the
morning you know I couldn't stay awake
in school like so like I remember I was
like in third grade no second grade and
I kept falling asleep in my desk and my
teacher took my desk away from me and
she made me like like stand up and so me
I'm like [__] you being this little kid
I just went and fell asleep on the
ground and mind you like the school
system's like oh Sean like he's just a
bad kid they don't realize I'm up till 3
o' in the morning like you know late I
mean [__] dude I remember it's hard to
stay up late and learn dude I remember
like laying in bed like I remember when
I stop believing God man like [__]
like I had [__] um yeah it's crazy
[__]
dude crazy [__] man yeah it's okay man
it's a lot of that said dude I used to
be scared at night like uh I used to
stand up like I heard when I was a kid
that like if you peed around your like
animals could pee somewhere that other
animals wouldn't come you know what I'm
talking about you know what I'm talking
about huh yeah have you ever heard
that yeah I'm sorry
bud so
man I'm sorry buddy that's all good
[Music]
dude we don't have talk man I can just
sit here with you for a
minute oh
[__] [__] just take a
second I can just sit here we can just
sit here it's all good you six second I
just process
it I
think it's one hard things that people
don't understand like trauma you know
yeah unless it just comes out oh no dude
like I
remember I have a hole in my
[Music]
gum yeah when I was a kid I used to
scratch my gum I have a hole in my gum
you know just from being nervous and
stuff no just anxi you know yeah even to
this day yeah I mean the day dude like
I'm a grown ass man I don't give a [__]
I mean you could post this I don't care
oh dude I don't have any no it's all
good dude I mean it's is what it is dude
like it is what it is like people
understand like when I talk about like
oh I kill a man it's like you don't
understand you're like when you go
through that level of trauma like you
just view the world differently you know
so it's like I have a hole in my gum cuz
I'd have so much much anxiety as a kid
and I would just scratch my gum until
like I mean just blood you know and you
know you're like you're in
pre-elementary school you don't know why
you're doing it yeah yeah [__] a I I
remember like like know like you don't
even know it is when you're a kid when
you're really talking about side like
being a little kid like laying in bed
like just like man I'm just [__] I'm
done with this [__] you know like there
can't be a God I know it makes me sad
yeah it's [__] up dude it just makes
me sad that a kid has to feel that way
you know yeah so like any kid whenever
drus goes on there and like he jokes
about that [__] right like dude you have
no idea yeah I mean and this is like as
a comedian you got to joke about trauma
like people think like I joke like I
joke about all this [__] like you know
as were're laughing like you got to joke
about like you got to joke about it if
you don't like how do you process that
you know how do you how do you process
that kind of abuse I mean I'll never
forget my
brother my brother we were like upstairs
once and he taped and he taped knives to
his [__] leg I mean we're talking
elementary school he was going to go sit
on the couch with my dad and stab him
dude like you know it's
like it's like that level of [__] you
know
yeah mix account with a killer man but
yeah yeah you [__] I mean we all we f
g the
[__]
your brother a pretty nice guy yeah he's
all right you know he's a close friend
yeah it's like it just gives you like
[__] you can't yeah you can't [__]
deal
with yeah man Life's good I make a lot
of money now I'm happy but you know did
you think like cuz yeah dud I remember
being so scared when I was a kid like I
was saying like I remember hearing that
like animals if you pee like animals if
animal peed some another animal wouldn't
come
so I would stand up on my bed at night
and I would pee around my bed in a
circle cuz I was afraid that things were
going to get me no [__] who were you
afraid like any particular just
everything everything I mean I was just
afraid of everything I mean you you
didn't really grow up with a dad you
know like I understand yeah I just have
anybody just teach me about anything I
was just like an I was just felt like
a I don't know I think I felt worthless
probably yeah but then I think not
having a dad's rough dude like I mean
you had a dad but like yeah but I think
not having somebody like communicate
with you or [__] treat you I don't
know I don't know what it was but I was
just really scared yeah that's why I
think when I see a lot of you guys like
I think there's a lot of guys out there
who [__] I wish I could have been even
able to defend myself in my neighborhood
or anything like I didn't have anybody
look out I you know I just didn't so I
think you know you see guys man like you
guys it's like at least you know even
though you're fighting each other it's
still like well you got to learn it you
got to want to be violent some I mean
there's some guys like you know there's
some guys like Jon Jones who's just a
he's a [__] athlete you know he's
just like there's some there's a lot of
athletes and there's guys like me who
were like if it wasn't for fighting bro
I would be jail I'd be in jail like it
it's not like like to have like you
don't understand like I I truly have a
deep down urge to kill somebody like I
can't it doesn't go away like I just
like I don't know what it is man like
you know you just think like yeah it's
[__] up dude you know so like when I
train it gives me tools to process it
but like there there's definitely
something inside me that like tells me
that like the moment I take someone's
life and now why you we could probably
agree that it's because you have so much
Tri and you're victimized that like
that's your way of like protecting you
and saying that if you go and kill
somebody like you'll be happy and I
would like I would if you could let me
kill a man like happy as I can't but
right some places some places right but
you know pull up in Memphis
can do what you want but see I don't
know like a lot of times I don't know
what it's like to to talk to normal
people yeah I have some people who know
exactly what it's like who've been
molested who've been abused you know and
it's like I have some people know you
know been beat up I have these people
know what it's like but to go talk to
the average person like man you just
don't know it's like some people do but
you don't know what it's like to be able
to like the only thing like that would
make me happy is the [__] literally
cave in your [__] skull and like the
only thing that would I truly want is
the [__] like make somebody hurt
[__] hurt yes you know and then the
problem is like it makes me Vol it makes
me volatile so I don't really even this
day like I don't go out much you can't
trust yourself probably I can't trust
myself